let's bring in ron jaworski the former
eagles quarterback he was in the booth
last night monday night football between
the seahawks and eagles alongside kevin
harlan
how's the arm when's the last time you
threw like a really hard
20-yard pass jaws uh probably about five
years ago i haven't thrown a meaningful
pass in about 30 years but
i could probably play arena football in
that short field all right
explain to me what the what the headline
should be after the eagles lost last
night or the sea
seattle seahawks win over the eagles
what should the headline be uh it
depends what city you're in
in philadelphia the headlines are not
pretty the fan base as you know in this
town's very passionate town
they are very very upset um yesterday
there was a lot of chatter
in the city of philadelphia about who
the quarterback was going to be
jeffrey luery was chiming in holly rosen
seemed to be chiming in
doug peterson deflecting the questions
um you know when you're a struggling
football team and you have a struggling
quarterback
it's hard it is really hard i've been
through it personally
now carson wins has to work his way
through it somehow some way
he has too much time to be playing like
he's playing right now
i was wondering though jaws do you sit
him down
and just let him kind of absorb it from
a different
perspective as opposed to just going
back out there and it feels like you get
into bad habits or your confidence level
starts to be depleted and i know jalen
hurts isn't ready for this
but i got to think long term about
carson wentz
uh how do you preserve him in a
situation like this
yeah as you know dan i you know i look
at every game on the coaches tape and
you evaluate that position about as
much as anybody and this has been a
really difficult one to figure out what
is wrong with carson wentz
um is it mechanical is it cerebral
is it mental is it the offensive line is
it the wide receiver is the play calling
is it the analytics i really can't put
my finger on it's kind of puzzling to me
because
carson wins has enormous talent um he's
got a rocket arm he could run he's
powerful he's big he's strong
if i would boil it down i would say he's
not seeing the field with clarity he
made some throws yesterday that were
kind of kind of
head scratchers as well and it's been
that way all season long
he has not played through 11 games a
solid game at quarterback
and in the national football league this
obviously a quarterback driven game
your quarterback must play to a high
level to win football games now
i'm not going to blame it all on him i
don't like jalen hurts coming in
for one or two snaps a game i went
through that back in the day with
randall cunningham or i would come out
on third and seven or more and randall
would come in and it just breaks down
the whole consistency
of playing the quarterback position i
think for the team as well as the
individual
uh but hey the legals have chose chosen
to go that way why i don't know
um but i thought we would see more jalen
hurts after eagles went
over five on their first three
possessions three and outs yeah i did
too
i just thought you know either put him
in or or don't put him in like you sort
of put him in and then you
you know you take him out and yeah as
you know it's all about
rhythm you get that rhythm going offense
gets the rhythm
you get confidence there but they don't
have any of that
would you would you start jalen hurts
there's there's a reason jalen hurts is
not starting
he's not good enough not that he won't
be someday
but with this pandemic that we're all
dealing with right now covenant 19
there was no off season those are
important there was no
training camp that's important there
were no preseason games to develop a
young quarterback
that's important i think it would be a
disservice to jalen hurts
to put him out there the number one goal
of the head coach in the team
is to win you want to put the best
players on the field that give you the
best chance to win
apparently from the coaching staff and
doug peterson
jalen hurts is not ready to step in you
know you could
damage a young quarterback for his whole
career and i always think of a guy that
always comes to my mind patrick ramsey
who i thought had enormous talent
with the washington football team now
but he got beat up so bad they were
losing
and he never recovered from that so this
is a football team right now in philly
that's in a transition phase this is not
a team that's going to compete
you know for the playoffs or a super
bowl for for a number of years right now
this team needs to be retooled now the
question then now is you have to ask
doug peterson
who are you going to retool with ask
howie roseman you know ask jeffrey
laurie who are you going to retool with
who's your quarterback going to be who
is the guy you're going to hang your hat
on for this next three to five years
who's more likely to be back next year
the coach or the quarterback
they'll both be back i i i i just think
it's so
unfair to evaluate coaches front office
people
you know the math patricia's the bill
o'brien's the dan quinn's these guys got
fired
i mean and football is a game of
creatures of habit you keep doing the
same thing over and over again
and that's been the farthest thing from
this season so these coaches have been
held accountable for things that are out
of their control
how would you like to be vic fan joe on
sunday
and running running out a football team
where your quarterback hasn't played in
two years and it was in college
and you expect to beat the warren saints
that's not fair to coaches
that's not fair to a football team and i
heard you talking earlier this is not
fair the way this season is playing out
we're talking to ron jaworski the former
eagles quarterback working for westwood
one and uh was on the broadcast call
with kevin harlan
last night what did you think of seattle
i think they're a good football team
that has a chance to be a a really good
football team russell wilson is
such a catalyst for them offensively and
jamal adams i'm telling you i
i open the telecast with if you're
watching this game
and when carson wins breaks from the
huddle he should locate number 33.
that's the guy that really is going to
dictate the tempo of the game he blitzes
about 24
of the time he's going to be the
catalyst for that football team when you
think of
you know earl thomas and cam chancellor
and the legion of doom
in seattle jamal adams brings that to
this football team and carlos dunlop a
mid-season acquisition
has given him that edge rusher that they
need so they're getting better
but how about dk metcalf this guy is on
he's unbelievable and i still don't
understand
darius slay shadowing him every single
play
jim schwartz please mix it up a little
bit i mean you know what you got he's
getting
beat for 177 yards go to some zone go to
some double teams
do something a little bit different it
didn't seem they did
i'm going to play this for you because
uh dk metcalf after the game talked
about jim schwartz
comparing him to calvin johnson i want
you to hear it and then i want
you to translate here for us jaws here's
dk metconf
what's your mindset going into a game
when you know or when you feel like
you're going to see
a lot of opposing teams number one
cornerback
what's your mindset going into it i'm
happy
i'm getting a little respect but you
know i still got work to do
one of the defensive coaches came up to
me and it kind of made me mad that he
was like
um you know i was i was in detroit with
uh megatron but you're not there yet
um you know in my mind i'm not trying to
be megatron i'm trying to be me so
um you know i had a little chip on my
shoulder the whole game
was that jim schwartz uh yes sir
all right interpret this what was jim
was jim schwartz trying to complement dk
metcalf
yes i believe so i don't think he was
over there and being antagonistic to him
i think he
has great respect for him uh and
certainly megatron was a great player
and jim schwartz was in detroit when he
was there so he's very familiar with him
and they are both elite athletes so
megatron was and
certainly not dk metcalf and and dan
you've been around this game long enough
you know what goes on pregame
you know these coaches are out there
with their business cards in their
pocket because a lot of them are going
to get fired
and they're they're renewing old
acquaintances with other teams
and he probably ran in ran into dk and
twice
i don't see it as inflammatory you know
i don't see jim as that kind of guy he
could be quirky occasionally but he's
never been that kind of guy usually very
socially for the game
i thought it was a compliment because dk
metcalf is not calvin johnson
he reminds me he reminds me a little bit
more of t.o than
calvin johnson but uh it's still a
compliment when i say
hey but you're on your way he's only
been in the league a couple of years
yeah i mean if someone came up to me
pregame and said hey jaws you look like
joe namath i'd be like really happy
wow that's a real compliment you know
yeah but if if they came
they said you look like him you didn't
play like him you just look like him
yeah i i get it did you cross paths with
namath
oh yeah yeah you know i you know i was a
i grew up in buffalo new york a suburb
called lachawan and i was a
buffalo bill season ticket holder and
those are the old afl days you know the
you know the bills and the jets at that
time and
you know i went to i went to a game and
in those days you could literally walk
right on the field or about five yards
from the field and uh
joe nameless warming up in the end zone
i remember seeing old number 12 there
just spin it
i'm going there i could do that i could
do that so it kind of gave me some
some motivation to want to work hard at
my craft but also
name it threw an effortless ball i don't
and he had those
real small shoulder pads but he had
he threw a beautiful deep ball i i don't
know what the difference is like what is
that jaws where
warren moon threw maybe the best deep
ball i've ever seen jeff
george threw a great deep ball but what
is it about that ability
damn throw this guy in there jeff blake
i thought for a number of years the
bengals won the best deep ball through
some guys you know russell wilson right
now throws that high arcing rainbow that
drops down the chimney
you know right in the receiver's hand so
it's getting on those deep balls you got
to get the nose up
and the good trajectory on the football
some guys just have that art
you know and usually power throwers and
quite honestly that's what i i was as a
player and i see a lot of guys
power throwers have a tougher time with
that deep high arcing throw because
they're so used to firing these you know
bullets in there to between
linebackers and safeties and secondary
players so it's harder to develop that
deep high arcing throw
well speaking of the deep ball tom brady
in that offense in tampa bay
are they running the right offense for
brady's skill set
yes i i i i'm bewildered by some of the
comments
that i you know that i hear from other
people and again i i base a lot of you
know
my feeling on this screen that i have
right back there and i watch all the
you know the coaching tape on that
screen and and tom brady is still
playing at a very
high level it's going to take some time
to assimilate
into this offense and it's a different
style of offense but tom brady
eventually will get this
and they're going to be a force to
recognize there's a lot of talent right
now
on that buccaneer offense it's going to
come together for him but why is there
this disconnect or it feels like there's
a little bit of tension there with
aryans
and and are we creating this jaws yes
yeah thank you dan i think i i really
think you know i think the media just
looking for
something to talk about um you know you
got tom brady i think everyone thought
they were going to go 16-0 because you
acquired
you know the greatest of all time the
gold and all these weapons
football is the consummate team game the
timing and rhythm of an offense has to
be
precise and exquisite it is not right
now but this receiving core down in
tampa is very very good they can run the
football i think their offensive line
has to pick their play up somewhat
because tom needs protection he's a
plant step and throw guy
he's not going to be mobile and slide
and move around the pocket so
he needs help from his offensive line
and and it's the the defense by the way
todd bowles done a really good job with
his defense i think eventually they get
a bye this week
they're going to start coming together
there's way too much talent okay we were
just ripping jim schwartz for his
defense on dk metcalf what the hell was
todd bowles in the buccaneers thinking
single coverage on tyreek hill
uh i wish i could answer that john
i have no idea i mean he only had 207
yards
in the first quarter he was on pace for
a thousand-yard receiving game
jaws a thousand yards yeah i agree i
think two of those coverages were blown
coverages by the way
uh but hey you know you you still and
look at the dimes that muhammad's
through though he
he you know there was there was a couple
wide open and a couple of great throws
but that's what you get with patrick
will holmes that's what you get with the
terry kill that's what you get with
jason kelsey
i mean there is an incr that's a wealth
of a wealth of talent
on that chief's offense they're going to
do that to a lot of people always great
to talk to you jaws
thank you thanks dan you're the best
thank you buddy that's ron jaworski
former eagles quarterback and uh
i worked with jaws at the mothership for
a long time he was on the call last
night with
the great kevin harlan in the monday
night booth